hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar pgta simplified
which of the leading ngs solutions is
easiest to implement
i am michelle ashton of labrums and i'll
be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar
is presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
rh let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker adam
goodman
the director of pre-implantation
genetics at nextgen
ndx for a complete biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
adam you may now begin your presentation
welcome
thank you for the introduction my name
is adam and i run the pgt
department for nextgen mdx a us-based
genetics lab located in grand rapids
michigan
whether you're expecting or one day hope
to be genetic screening can help you
make informed decisions about
how to move forward the nextgen mdx
would make it our mission to ensure our
patients have access to best-in-class
science unrivaled accuracy and personal
genetic counseling
designed to help them chart a course for
their family's future
to that end we offer our clients a host
of best-in-class services
including state-of-the-art carrier
screening pre-implantation genetic
testing
non-invasive pregnancy testing
hereditary cancer screening
molecular vaginosis testing and more
recently we have become the largest
kovid 19 testing laboratory
in the state of michigan having run over
300 000 tests since march
today we'll be focusing on pgt and a
technical research study our team
performed comparing two of the leading
ngs-based pgta assays
i have been working in the pgt field for
over 10 years now
when i first started out we were still
using fish and pcr-based tests to assess
chromosomal composition
in day three embryo biopsies and i've
been able to experience firsthand the
evolution of pgp through many different
platforms
today we'll be discussing two of the
world's most widely utilized and trusted
assays
the long-time champion of
high-resolution pgta veraseek pgs
originally designed by illumina now
owned by vitrilife
and the more recent newcomer represent
pgs by thermo fisher scientific
as the head of pre-implantation genetics
for next-gen
a key part of my job is to always be on
the lookout for new technologies to
advance our pgt program
and for almost a decade i have been
using very seek i still believe it is a
good product however i am always open to
new ideas
and when the latest version of thermos
represent essay came along
it proposed to offer the same level of
higher resolution sequencing diversity
with an easier protocol and lower price
since the next gen we employ both
illumina and thermal fissure sequencers
on a large scale in our other divisions
we are fortunate in that we can easily
switch between
sequencing platforms for pgpa we decided
to give the reference to the essay a try
to see if it would meet our high
standards in the past having spent
many years behind the bench as a lab
technician and now on the directorial
side of things i am well versed in value
evaluating new pgp products as such i
ran the representative through its paces
and afterwards i was asked by thermal
fisher if i would be willing to share my
experience
before i get to the experiments i want
to talk about what i look for in a pgta
assay the goal of pgta as a science
is to identify those embryos with the
greatest potential of resulting in a
healthy pregnancy and baby
to best accomplish this goal we need an
assay that has a resolution high enough
to accurately detect not just whole
chromosomal gains and losses
but also smaller segmental deletions and
duplications as research studies have
shown that they too can be responsible
for reduced implantation and increased
miscarriage rates
at the same time we must be sure that
the anapoly events that we are detecting
really exist
if an assay does not provide tools to
properly investigate
sample and data quality it will be prone
to false poverty
and finally cost i would be lying if i
told you cost is not a big factor
the pgpa field has become extremely
competitive over the last decade
many of our ivf lab clients are big
believers in improving their success
rates
with pgt and lower cost means greater
utilization
as such without overwhelming evidence of
superior technology
even modest price increases are not
going to be accepted in this field
here are some of the key aspects of any
prospective pdta
assays that need evaluation resolution
and accuracy i want to know that essay
provides true
24 chromosome high resolution data with
the ability to reliably identify mosaic
and segmental anemoploids
reliability and precision running
isolated genomic dna through a pdta
assay is easy you're going to get great
quality data every time because you have
a pristine quality sample
i am more interested in testing out real
world analogs of variable quality
because in practice not all samples
received by our lab are going to be
perfect
data interpretation does the app that
provides strong software capable of
allowing our lab to thoroughly
investigate samples
not just for anti-parties but also for
assessing the quality of the data itself
that we can better separate sample noise
and amplification artifacts from true
aberrations
this is a challenging task and as far as
i know nextgen is the only company
willing to provide
pgta data analysis and reporting
services
separate from the lab work side of it
throughput and ease of use
how long does the essay take to run how
much of that time is hands on and how
amenable is the assay to automation
and finally i want to know more about
the associated costs than just the per
sample price under ideal circumstances
i want to know what samples per run size
options are available
and the total run cost associated with
each
very few labs have enough sample volume
to fill every run to its maximum
you need to know what your cost will be
for runs performed on a 100
capacity labor costs are also another
important factor
what level of experience is required and
for how long at the various stages of
sample handling
essays that use more automation can free
up senior technician time
without reducing quality additionally
there can be significant differences in
ancillary costs such as plastic
consumables
and safety equipment a note on pgt
asa resolution yes it is possible to
dramatically lower the cost of the pgpa
assay by turning down the resolution
whether you're using an illumina flow
cell or
thermos ion sequencing chip each has a
limited amount of physical space
available that can be utilized to gather
sequence data from samples it is simple
math
lower resolution means more samples fit
on the sequencing chip
and the more you can cram onto a chip
the lower your cost per sample
doubling the number of samples run on a
chip halves your cost per sample
but it also has the amount of sequencing
data that can be gathered from each
sample
and this can seriously inhibit your
ability to detect smaller dilutions in
duplication
so how exactly does this happen changes
in chromosomal copy number do not have
to occur as whole chromosome gains and
losses
and such a higher resolution athlete is
inherently better at detecting partial
anaphor events
because you cannot detect deletions and
duplications in areas where you have no
coverage
looking at the example on this slide
imagine one is sequencing only the gray
regions of this chromosome
but what if our deletion occurs in the
green region here outlined by the yellow
box
because the assay is only looking in the
gray regions it would not detect the
loss and if they old implantation or
miscarriage is the most likely outcome
such partial anapoly events can occur
randomly or in the case of
translocations that can be driven
towards specific locations with high
frequency
this is a big deal because studies have
put the percentages of pgta embryos with
segmental anapolis and around eight
percent
that means if your assay cannot see
these your misdiagnosis rate could be as
high as one in twelve
yes lowering the resolution can lower
the cost of the test
but it's simply not worth the risk
for our investigation of resolution we
purchased 10 different commercially
available cell lines with known
abnormalities ranging in size from
whole chromosome down to 1.5 megabases
one important distinction here is that
we tested actual intact cells
not isolated dna as is used in most
assay manufacturer validation studies i
believe that this approach provides a
better analog of real world performance
with regards to biopsies
we diluted cell suspensions down to the
amount found in typical pgp biopsies
aliquoting approximately five to ten
cells per collection tube
we then ran them multiple times through
both the veriseek and rougher stick
platforms
to see if we could empirically find any
difference in their limit of detection
with regards to the size of segmental
deletions and duplications
what we found was both assays
outperformed their manufacturer's stated
stock resolutions and 10
megabase pairs reliably detecting
segmental changes down to about five
megabases
before we started to see any missed
calls both assays showed identical
results for all samples
not just in the limits of detection but
all the corresponding copy number charts
for virtual overlays of each other
here are two example copy number
variation plots from the experiment
chromosome numbers listed across the
x-axis and copy numbers listed across
the y
i realize the numbers are hard to see
but basically what one is looking for is
movement
away from a baseline of two copies for
chromosome
on the y-axis with these samples there
are only two
areas that show such aberrations all the
way to the right you can see a loss in
copy number of chromosome y
which is expected here this is a female
sample and a little to the left
of that our copy number for chromosome
21 has jumped from two to three
indicating trisomy 21. what is
particularly interesting about this
sample is that both reproductive
conversely saw a
full gain of chromosome 21 when the cell
line was previously karyotype that's
having only a 33
megabase duplication on chromosome 21.
neither athlete showed any indication of
euploidy in any area of chromosome 21.
the most likely explanation is that
represent various things have a higher
resolution
than the array-based assay used in the
original karyotyping in the sample
however as we tested actual intact cells
and not
isolated genomic dna is also possible
that the abnormality is unstable
in the cell line culture
assessment of accuracy we again wanted
to test an analog more rigorous than
isolated dna
we partnered with an ivf lab in florida
to retest embryos that were previously
predicted to be
unemployed by a third party using a snip
based array platform
since the experiment involved learning
the samples simultaneously through both
the rupert c
conversing platforms this was helpful in
that it could potentially provide a tie
breaker in the event of a discrepancy
between the two ngs based
acids additionally we tested not just a
trifecta and biopsy from these samples
but also
the remainder of the whole embryos
themselves to assess concurrence between
biopsy
and embryo calls after all the whole
point of pgta is to be able to correctly
predict the quality of the embryo
22 embryos yielding 44 unique samples
made it into the study
connection was blind to the third-party
anapoly predictions
which sample tubes contain biopsies
which contained whole embryos
and also to which embryo a given biopsy
belongs
we found a hundred percent concordance
between represent
at the fundamental level of calling a
sample normal or abnormal we also saw
100
concordance between the biopsies and
their corresponding whole embryo sample
however we did see two instances in
which the abnormalities detected in the
biopsies did not perfectly match that
seen in the whole
embryo sample those sample sets
are seen here in red and they are not
necessarily surprising
in that the abnormalities detected or
related even though they are not perfect
matches
other studies have shown that with
mosaic samples we sometimes see
variations of the same abnormality when
the sample is biopsied
multiple times which is the trisomy in
one biopsy
and a reciprocal monotony in another
biopsy from the same
embryo
the more shocking discovery we made was
that four of the embryos previously
predicted to be abnormal by third-party
snip array
were found to be euploid by ngs in these
instances
both the biopsy and the whole embryo
samples were found to be euphoid on
both the represent and variously
platforms
these samples are highlighted in red
there were three other discrepancies
between the third party testing and our
two ngs based
assays seen in blue however in these
instances again the abnormalities were
related
and likely implicate technical
limitations of the snip assay
and or embryo mosaicism as the cause of
the discordance
so how could nearly 20 percent of the
embryos predicted to be anaploid by a
third-party snip array turn out to be
euploid
on our two ngsa platforms
the acid is theoretically possible that
mosaicism could account for the
difference
however i find that scenario extremely
unlikely
for this to happen it would not only
mean that nearly 20 percent of the
embryos we tested were true mosaics
but it would require two fundamental
conditions to be true on
four separate occasions as we saw four
discrepant embryos
first no euploid cells could have been a
part of the original biases set for
slippery testing
this biopsy must have been composed of
only anaploid cells
and second all our most anaploid cells
from this hypothetically mosaic embryo
would have to have been excised from the
embryo during the original biopsy
such the vocal biopsy and the remainder
of the embryo which was sent to mexican
could contain no unemployed itself
to understand why this is extremely
unlikely we must first understand a
little about the ideology of
embryonic mosaicism a mosaic embryo in
this context is an embryo that contains
a mixture of both anapoloid and euploid
cells
here we see three different types of
mosaic embryos with anaploid cells
represented in red
and euploid cells represented in green
anaploid cells can be confined to the
perfect intermediate
and as the trajectory goes on to form
the placenta this is known as confined
separator mosaicism
confined placental mosaicism can lead to
a false negative if the biopsy is taken
from an area which happens to contain no
anaploid or red cells embryos that
generalize mosaicism have anaeropoid
cells spread throughout their structure
this type of mosaicism is less likely to
result in this diagnosis
as a given biopsy is likely to contain
at least some anaploid cells
if the anaploid cells are confined to
the inner cell mass which goes on to
form the fetus it is known as fetal
metabolism
because our study tested the remainder
of the whole embryo in addition to a
second biopsy
at least eighty percent of the anaploid
cells would need to be removed from the
embryo during the original biopsies
performed for sniff
testing otherwise the angst-based
platforms would show
signs of abnormality as twenty percent
mercedes's
methane generally regarded as the limit
of detection for high resolution and gs
based pdta
assays this effectively rules out two of
the three types of embryonic
monarchicism first embryologists are
trained to not biopsy the inner cell
mass of the embryo
because this is the region of the
umbrella goes on to form the fetus
for this to be accidentally done on two
separate occasions
with four different embryos is thus
highly unlikely
this rules out fetal mosaicism the next
time we are to generalize mosaicism have
anaploid cells scattered randomly
throughout the embryo
making it virtually impossible to
perform a biopsy on the embryo and not
leave at least some anapoly cells behind
that would later be detected during the
testing of the whole embryo
this rules out generalized the racism
leaving us with just embryos in which
anaphoid cells are confined to an
isolated area of the trifecta
so assuming all four of these embryos
had confined placental mosaicism we
would still need some very specific
things to happen for the snip assay to
show an appointing while the ngs
assays showed you please
take a closer look during the first
biopsy for snip testing we would need to
see all or almost all of the anaploid
cells
removed from the embryo but with no
euploid cells tagging along
those anaploid cells would then move on
to undergo smith-based pgta
leading to the third-party anaploid
result
next the second biopsy the one tested by
our team would need to be taken from an
area of the embryo with no anapoli cells
this biopsy then undergoes whole genome
amplification
and since referencing conversions use
the same whole genome amplification
chemistry
the wgj product can be split and
sequenced separately on the two
different platforms if no anaploid cells
were contained in the second biopsy
both ngs assays would give a euploid
result
finally and this is the most unlikely
condition if both biopsies
occurred perfectly such that no anaploid
cells still reside
anywhere in the remainder of the embryo
then the whole
embryo was run on the two ngs based
platforms the euploid result could occur
i've included a few screenshots here the
cnb charts generated by our experiment
to demonstrate the great quality and
sample data we achieved
how confidently the discrepancy samples
were seen to be deployed
via the two ngs based platforms they
showed absolutely no trace of the
abnormalities previously predicted by
sniffer ray
here we see two sets of embryo trifecta
repairs
run volt on both represent and
raristique
with the gray and yellow charts
representing represent and the green
charts representing versus
so if mosaicism cannot account for the
discrepancy between the snip-based
assay and the results seen by both
ngs-based assays
but can't in my opinion the most
plausible explanation is that sample
noise was erroneously interpreted
as anapoly during snip analysis this is
a critical reason why we must have good
tools to properly assess the quality of
the data generated by a given sample
and why relying on ai software to
distinguish sample noise from true
abnormalities
is a bad idea here we see two examples
of samples that did not pass
quality control in our lab even to the
untrained ivs
copy number charts look drastically
different from the nice clean ones we
saw on previous slides
when there is this much sample noise one
cannot possibly provide
accurate results the proper call for
such samples is no call
and the embryophoidy status must be
treated as unknown
i'm a firm believer that it is better to
have more no calls than to risk
discarding
potentially euphoid embryos
next we wanted to test the reliability
and precision of the represent assay
first all samples from the resolution
study will run a second time to ensure
no call changes were seen
nonetheless then we failed an entire run
using only one sample 24 times
this sample had a net 140 percent mosaic
trisomy x
karyotype and was used to check for
consistency in reads per sample
as well as percent nevada has been
detected by the republic
assay
we averaged over 145 000 reads per
sample after filtering
which was well above the manufacturer's
suggested cutoff of a hundred thousand
additionally we saw all samples stay
fairly close to the expected 40
mosaic value with a mean level of 39
this entire experiment was then repeated
by a second technician to verify
reproducibility of these numbers in the
new set of hands
overall the coefficient of variation for
reads after filtering was less than 10
percent
for both technicians indicating great
evenness and sample representation
across the reference sequencing chip
with regards to mosaicism we saw plus or
minus 10
from the expected value of 40 these
numbers are spot on with what i have
seen over the years with the various
weak assay
and thousands of samples tested and both
represent what i believe to be the
current best available precision for a
commercial pgta platform
however it also represents one of the
reasons why i do not think it is a good
idea to stratify
the racism into low-level and high-level
groupings on reports
as you can see even under
unrealistically ideal
circumstances the exact same sample
could show up
as low level 30 mosaic in one instance
and high level 50 mosaic in another a
difference of 20
even within the very same sequencing
room
it is better to report only what is seen
rather than to attach a conclusion to
the embryo
which may be untrue
i'd like to take a moment here to
discuss reads per sample because i have
heard concerns in the field pertaining
to veriseek
achieving far more reads for sample the
represent
but looking at only reads per sample is
not a fair comparison
first on average a much larger percent
of reads are usable with represent
compared to veriseek
85 versus 50 but more importantly the
read length is much longer with
represent
110 base pairs per read compared to 36
base pairs with varices
that means our average of 145 000
utilized reads per sample
equates to 16 million total base pairs
with frequency
and five hundred thousand reads utilize
when pharisee equates to eighteen
million base pairs which is a far
cry from the difference implied by
someone stating that various seek
generates
a million reads per sample compared to
145 000 with references
nonetheless it's true that vericy can
generate slightly more data per sample
than represent
and that is precisely why we ran our
experiment
i needed to know empirically do their
differences result in different outcomes
and all of our data said no both
athletes yielded identical results on
all samples
tested
having found the resolution accuracy to
be the same between representing
conversation
we then take a closer look at software
and protocol differences
with regards to data analysis software
we found that the ion reporter software
used by represented offer some exciting
new features compared to the now agent
bluetooth software used by verizon
ion reporter can automatically flag
segmental and mosaic anaploidy events
whereas bluefuse can only make
chromosomal calls the bluefuse which is
still possible to make segmental and
mosaic calls based on the cnb
charts but the software cannot flag them
automatically
it's a flag because they do not believe
in setting card thresholds in this
racism for a whole host of reasons but
long story short i think
every sample called anapoy deserves the
attention of an expert analyst to
properly assess the validity of the call
i compared to the recapture security
features we encounter online
utilized by websites to determine
whether a user is human
the computer cannot be relied upon to do
as simple a task as determining
which of the tiles in this picture
contains street signs
how can we possibly rely on ai to sort
through millions of genomic data points
to tell us which pgt samples in the zig
and the same goes for segmental
deletions and duplication
the human mind is still the best image
recognition device in the world
it's not to say i don't want the
software to apply possible in the
basicism
that's really important i just believe
that manual review is still essential at
this point in time
the ion reporter software also includes
coverage maps for the assessment of data
quality
and it allows for the use of custom
baselines should we ever need to use a
different amplification method
say for example when using multiple
displacement amplification
for targeting the difficult to amplify
single gene
disorder for concurrent pgpm testing
both the repercussion conversation
protocols can be done inside 12 hours
but we find more practically they can be
split over two work days
the rep receipt protocol can utilize
three different size sequencing chips
allowing for run sizes of
16 24 and 96 samples while the verisig
protocol has
only one chip size intended to run
twenty four samples at a time
or genome amplification for both wrapper
c converts
chemistry and the wga workflow is
essentially identical with the exception
of adding barcode
indices in the third stage of the wga
process with represent
which allows for cooling of the samples
prior to template preparation
the biggest difference between the two
assays represents plug-and-play
automation of the lengthy and sensitive
template preparation chemistry
needed prior to sequencing this is
accomplished via thermo's iron chef
robot
it essentially frees up five hours of
tech time compared to the manual versus
protocol
additionally the ion chef gives you the
great flexibility
and that it allows you to dictate
precisely when you would like the robot
to finish
you can tell it to be done in as fast as
five hours regardless of the run size
or you can tell it to finish up at say
nine am the following morning
so the sequencing chip is ready to load
onto the sequencer
at the beginning of the next workday
you can see the overall protocol length
is very similar for these two assays of
the 24 sample per run level
however represent does have a scaling
advantage as variseq is limited to a
capacity of 24 samples
reverse each additional set of 24
samples will add
three hours of sequencer time plus at
least an hour of extra prep time
and that's assuming all samples are
prepped simultaneously
to prep separately the total time
doubles
with regards to hands-on times reported
by manufacturers you must be careful to
note the duration and frequency of
breaks between steps
for example though the template
preparation portion of the varsity
protocol requires only 90 minutes of
direct hands-on time
in practice our technicians are tied up
for about five hours
because the longest break in the
protocol is just 35 minutes
i think the more practical metric here
is uninterrupted hands-off time
both assays afford the user about an
hour of free time during the whole
genome application process
but the ion chef robot frees up an extra
four and a half hours
of usable tech time compared to the
manual veriseek library prep
and finally cost our lab saw only a
modest reduction in kit costs for rep
receipt compared to their seek about 15
at the 24 sample per run level however
the record stick works will also offer
some less repair but
very substantial benefit first because
the wrappers examples are barcoded
during the whole genome multiplication
stage
they can be pooled before downstream
processing
this makes the rubber stick workflow
much simpler and results in far less lab
wear being used as opposed to the
verisig protocol
where samples cannot be pulled until
right before loading the sequencer
after whole genome amplification the
represent protocol essentially uses the
same amount of reagents in plastic
whether processing one or 96 samples
with 96 samples in the veristic workflow
you use at least 96 times more tips
plate wells purification beads etc
does this drastically alter the cost per
sample no
player easily tax on a couple hundred
dollars per run which adds up over time
additionally unlike veriseek the
reference to cafe does not utilize
hazardous reagents
which means you did not need to invest
in the fume hood and you do not need to
pay for expensive hazardous waste
disposal
but the feature that grabbed my
attention the most with rapper secrets
how much simpler more reliable the
workflow is
using their ion chef robot to fully
automate template preparation
copy number assays inherently involve
sensitive reactions that require
experienced and expertly trained
laboratory technicians to achieve
high quality results consistently being
able to automate going
from pool to ready-to-sequence chip on
the ion chef
allows us to run more samples with fewer
expert technicians
while simultaneously removing some of
the human imprecision from the process
in summary we were quite impressed with
the represent pgs platform
empirically we could find nothing that
versus could detect that reprocedu could
not
and subjective when you found the
representative much easier to use
the ion chef makes processing samples
much simpler and data interpretation is
also
easier on the more powerful ion
reporters software
combined with the reduction in costs we
have found represent to currently be the
best assay for our lab
and is now what we use on a daily basis
of next-gen mdx
i'd like to end by saying that i love
that there is an exemplary newcomer in
the pgta space
in my opinion veristiq pgs had no
equivalent competition for nearly a
decade
and likely because of that i saw next to
no innovation on their product over that
stretch of time
competition fosters innovation and the
team at thermal fischer did a great job
listening to the needs of those in the
pgta field
i can personally vouch for the fact that
they are regularly reaching out to
myself and other pgt
experts for guidance on how to make the
next version even better
i'm glad to see this because as much as
i have enjoyed
working with their team my first and
foremost goal will always be
quality so keep up the good work therma
and with that i'll hand it off to
carolyn mack senior market development
manager of reproductive health and
thermal fissure scientific
thank you very much adam for a very
informative talk like adam said i'm
caroline mack and i'd like to stop
opportunity or take this opportunity to
share a little bit more
about our solutions that can help meet
your goals
so let's uh start from the top
again as you probably already know
reproductive health has a very broad
portfolio
but if we look at these this life cycle
starting from
the left with our carrier screening
portfolio we have our microarray
product called carrier scan but then our
newcomer
is carrier seek and that is done on our
ngs platform and it screens
for 420 genes
moving on to the right we have our
pre-implantation genetic testing
solutions the reproceed
that you have just heard about and
recently we added
pgdc as well that is our pgtm
solution if you go down continuing down
to the
right and the left there is a prenatal
and post-natal solution as well
and that is our high density snip
microarray
and at the bottom we have newborn
screening
which we will have offerings soon so
stay tuned for that
again all these innovations and
solutions
is really to help future generations be
healthier
and also to accelerate growth with
a comprehensive menu of reproductive
health solutions for
you and again with our follow the sun
model we provide the top-notch customer
service to keep your lab
running day night now i want to
move move on to our questions and
answers
section so i'm going to turn it over to
michelle our moderator
thank you very much adam and caroline
for your presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we will answer as
many questions as we have time for today
all right let's go ahead and get started
our first question is
how long did it take to compare the pgg
platforms
that took us about three months to do
but
most of that time was uh spent
trying to find a partner lab and obtain
the samples
to test for the portion of the study in
which you were comparing
embryos had been previously tested by
sniper ray to the ngs based
platforms i think if it was easier for
your lab to
obtain samples say you're an ivf lab you
could do it much faster than that
the testing itself could be done in a
couple weeks i think
thanks adam okay next question what were
the two biggest deciding
factors for a transition to retrofieq
so first and foremost it's quality we
had to be
absolutely certain that we weren't
giving up anything
in a move to a new pgta assay
we wanted to know um you know it's
a thing of uh trust but verify the term
i'm looking for we wanted to
look at the marketing materials and then
put it to the test they empirically
um you know it really doesn't matter
what the manufacturers are saying
we want to know does a difference
in the in the platform result in a
difference in the outcome
and we saw it didn't so that was
the first thing that we had to verify
and once we knew that that was true
then we placed more importance on other
ancillary things
like capital costs cost of the assay
uh ease of use assuming a lab
tech time all those things then came
into play and they were all in favor of
represent so that's why we ultimately
made the decision
to move to their assay
great thank you now what recommendations
can you make to anyone who wants to test
the leading pgt
platforms in their own lab
uh again i would say you really want to
get your hands on it
and and try it out for yourself um
i know that can be easier said than done
depending on on your particular
situation if you don't have
the sequencing equipment in your lab
work with your local representatives
see if if demos are a possibility
if you know another lab that has the
equipment that you can run around but
really
you need to have first hand experience
to know if it's the right choice for
your lab
thank you so much and again to the
audience any questions that we did not
have time for today
will be addressed by our seekers via the
contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
so thank you so much adam and caroline
for your time today adam do you have any
final comments for
our audience before we go
no i would just like to thank you for
having me and thank everyone for
listening
thank you again adam for your time today
and for your research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
goodbye